(soft whooshing)
(light beeping)
(lighthearted rhythmic music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is Dr. Harold Smith.
Dr. Smith holds the
appointment of distinguished
resident scholar with the
Institute of Governmental Studies
at the University of
California at Berkeley,
where he focuses on the
impact of technology
on foreign and defense policy.
He received his PhD from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
served as Professor of
Nuclear Engineering at the
University of California
Berkeley, and served as
Assistant Secretary of Defense
in the Clinton Administration.
He serves as an Advisor
to prime contractors,
(mumbles) tanks, and
national laboratories.
Dr. Smith is a fellow of the
American Physical Society
and a Commander in the
legion of honor of France.
He has trice received the
highest honor granted by
the Department of
Defense for Civil Service
the distinguished Public Service Award.
Harold, welcome to our program.
- A pleasure to be here, Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
born in a very small
city to the Southeast.
Moved early in my high
school years to Bellevue,
Pennsylvania, first suburb out the Ohio,
a very solid middle class suburb,
and we were very solid
middle class family,
which I should add right now
was a strong republican (mumbles).
- And what got you interested
in science and math?
- I think genetically it was always there,
but the key event that
sparked a love of mathematics
that I have to this day
was the father of the girl
I was dating.
He happened to be one of
the finest high school
mathematics teachers in
the city of Pittsburgh.
And I would take his very
lovely daughter, Mary Lou,
to the movies.
We did things like that then.
(man laughing)
And Mr. Horner was waiting
for me when we came home.
All of that was quite
normal in those days.
And Mr. Horner knew that
I did well in mathematics
and had a few questions for me and
we would start to talk,
and talk, and talk.
And finally, Mary Lou went to bed and
Mr. Horner and I continued
talking about mathematicians,
mathematics, I was fascinated.
- So, he wasn't interested
in your intentions as much
mentoring you in mathematics.
(man laughing)
- That's exactly right,
but my parents didn't see it that way.
When I would arrive home
from a movie night at 1:00
in the morning, there was
a lot of explaining to do.
- So then, where did you
do your undergraduate work
and your PhD?
- MIT, MIT, MIT, all my degrees.
- And what did you major
in as an undergraduate?
- As an undergraduate I was going to be
a captain of industry,
so I started in business,
I had a Stone National Scholarship,
a very generous scholarship,
otherwise I would've
never gone to a place
as prestigious as MIT.
I soon learned that
mathematics was more important
than accounting and
shifted to the extent that
time and curriculum was allow
to mechanical engineering
(mumbles) physics option.
- And then in graduate school,
what was your work there?
- The Tonic Energy Commission,
now the Department of Energy,
had just initiated nuclear
energy technology fellowships.
I was fortunate to get
one and that supported
the three years that I
needed to get the PhD
in nuclear engineering.
- And what were your
interests beyond physics,
as you were doing your dissertation work?
- In preparing for my doctoral exam,
everyone needs a break
and, of course, I did, too.
So, I read War and Peace by Leo Tolstoy.
And I did pass the doctoral exam,
but I became fascinated
with Russian literature.
And about the same time, the
Boston Symphony Orchestra
provided very inexpensive
tickets to their open rehearsals
and I began to go to those and
a lot of Russian music was played.
So, I developed a love of
Russian culture, history,
literature, and then when
I came to Cal, of course,
I met Nicholas Riasanovsky.
And as far as I'm concerned,
had written the definitive
history of Russia, and I read his history,
then I had the great
pleasure of meeting Nicky.
(men laughing)
- And so, in a way, you
were preparing for a future
that you didn't know yet would happen,
I'm talking now about
the Russian part of your
self education.
- You're absolutely right,
it was all serendipity.
- And then, what was your dissertation on,
and what was important
in that dissertation
that added another piece to this puzzle?
- Well, that's a very
good question because
the jargon of the day if one
wants to describe something
as difficult, you say, well,
it isn't rocket science,
implying of course that
rocket science is difficult.
And in my case, the title of my thesis was
The Dynamics in Control
of Nuclear Rocket Engines.
So, I am not only a rocket scientist,
I am a nuclear rocket scientist.
But those fields, to
jump ahead as you did,
were extremely important and
valued by the Russian elite,
certainly the intelligence.
So, in a same sense as
you said previously,
it was a running start into
what the Russians like.
- And your work with the
Russians will become very
important shortly, but you
also were making use of
the insights of a Russian mathematician
in the work that you were doing.
- Yes, when I came to Cal,
I continued work in dynamics
in control of interesting nuclear systems.
And I, one of the papers
that I'm most pleased with
is based on the theorems of Pontryagin,
a blind Russian
mathematician, early 1900's.
And his theorems allowed
me to solve a problem that,
modestly, even Farmian Vignor
couldn't solve, analytically.
They solved it with
very clever engineering
and that worked, but in this case,
I optimized the situation
and I could not have done it
without Pontryagin's theorems.
- So, after getting your
degree, you come to Cal
and you are a Professor in
the Nuclear Engineering Department.
- Right.
- So, how do we understand
the movement from
Berkeley to Washington,
because after serving
at Cal for almost a
decade, you decided to move
to a new career.
- Not quite, I took a
sabbatical after six years
on the faculty, and was
fortunate enough to win
a White House fellowship,
which of course took me
to Washington for a year.
Johnson was President.
I asked to be assigned to Robert McNamara,
each fellow was assigned
to a different department.
So, I had the pleasure of working with,
or at least reporting
to, Secretary McNamara.
That was an eye opening experience and
showed to me there's a
real place, a real need,
for people in academia to participate
in the real world of Washington DC.
- And to work for McNamara
and with his whiz kids
must have really been exciting.
- To say the least, and very rewarding.
Those friendships, Johnny
Foster being one of them,
the former director of Livermore,
and then the Director of Events
Research and Engineering,
really took me under his wing
and gave me some wonderfully
interesting assignments.
- And so, you wound up
staying in Washington
and going into consulting.
- I did come back to Cal, but shortly,
shortly thereafter, I actually
retired from the faculty
and pursued high level
management consulting
in the aerospace industry,
as well as some start ups
that (mumbles) worked out very well.
- And I always like to ask my guests what
they see as the skills and temperament
involved in the work they do.
So, you are both a scientist,
you're something of
a mathematician, and
then you wound up doing
consulting work and working
on policy in Washington.
So, what's the answer there?
What did you learn in the
process of these different
vocations and what skills in retrospect
do you see as really important?
- It's a good question, Harry.
I think what I learned the
most (mumbles) as a Professor
teaching mostly graduate students was that
once you'd listen, these graduate students
are very intelligent people.
And their questions and
their comments are worth it.
Furthermore, you don't bluff
with graduate students,
just tell it as it is.
If you know it, explain it.
If you don't know it,
say you don't know it
and go back and get the answer.
That really works in the world
of high level consulting.
These CEO's or Vice Presidents,
they wanna talk and
they want your reaction.
They don't need my
solution to their problems,
they need a sounding board,
a way to think through their problems.
So, what I learned
teaching in graduate school
was an enormous help, I found,
in the world of consulting.
- But what about creativity
in that kind of work
and policy circles, or in consulting?
In other words, is it the
interplay of listening
and thinking, getting reactions?
What help you come up with new solutions?
- Another good question, Harry.
What's going on, of course,
a consultant comes in
from the outside, doesn't
know the airplane industry,
or any other industry all that well,
certainly not compared to the
people that he's advising,
but that means I bring in a
new way of looking at things
so that I could be creative
in the sense of asking
some very stupid questions,
but also some questions
that they hadn't thought
of because they live
in their world and I live in mine,
and two came together,
quite often, very nicely.
- So, as you're in Washington
now, the Cold War is still
going on, you were
something of a cold warrior.
And I don't mean that
in a pejorative sense,
but in the sense that
you were focused a lot on
American security, on defense issues,
and you actually were chairman
of a scientific committee
to examine the vulnerability
of nuclear weapons.
Tell us about nuclear weapons themselves.
Tell us about that role.
- The Defense Science Board
had a number of task forces,
but one of the most important was
the Vulnerability Task
Force, just as you said.
That was an assembly of about a dozen top
level physicists, all of us
had the right clearances.
And we would investigate
ways that the Russians
might be trying to eliminate
our strategic advantage.
We even went so far as to
invent ways for the Russians
to put us at a disadvantage.
And we reported to then
Deputy Secretary Packard,
he was in the Nixon administration.
And some of the ideas that we explored,
some of the ideas that came
to us through intelligence
were not all that comforting.
So, over the decade that
I chaired this committee,
I became a real cold
warrior, I certainly didn't
trust the Russians, and I had ample
reason to not trust them.
So, in that sense, I was a
free (mumbles) cold warrior.
- And to what extent in the
consulting job in this work
does the mindset of a
scientist really enhance
your ability to do these tests?
- That's a...
I'll stop complimenting you, Harry.
(men laughing)
But it is a good questions.
Science is a very linear way of thinking.
A, B, C, D, E.
No distractions, so
that we would focus on a
particular problem and solve it,
or at least know the ramifications.
We didn't have to factor in
all of the political aspects
of how would he react to
that or she react to this.
It was strictly scientific
thinking and then,
of course, good expression afterwards.
- Time passes and you wind up joining
the Clinton administration.
How did you come to work
for the Defense Department
under President Clinton,
then Secretary Perry?
- In the course of this consulting,
and certainly with the
Vulnerability Task Force,
I met Bill Perry.
Dr. Perry was the Under
Secretary for Acquisition
in the Carter administration,
and when that administration
came to an end, Dr. Perry
began building his team,
waiting for the next
democratic presidency.
He had to wait quite a while.
But I was a member of that
team, I didn't know it,
but Bill was recruiting
people to work with him
if and when a democratic became President.
- So, a sort of shadow government.
- A shadow government,
very good way to put it,
and very good people, John
Deutch, Paul Kaminski,
Ash Carter, they were
all, without knowing it,
we were all on the team,
which meant that when we
initiated our efforts in
the Clinton administration,
we were on the ground running.
We knew each other and trusted each other,
we knew our spheres of
intelligence, accuracy.
It was a good start.
- And so, when you took an appointment in
the Clinton administration,
what was your official title?
You were an Assistant Secretary for?
- Defense for Nuclear, Chemical,
and Biological Defense Systems,
weapons of mass destruction.
It was a wonderful portfolio
and included responsibility
for the safety and security
of the nuclear stockpile,
except for those weapons in
control of the commanders.
Destruction of our own chemical weapons
through the (mumbles) Program,
which I hope we discuss,
the Russian chemical
weapons, making sure we were
ready for biological warfare if it came.
And as time went on, Dr.
Perry asked me to take
on things like counter
proliferation because
of the possible spread of
nuclear weapons, et cetera.
As one of my deputy's put it,
it was a very eclectic portfolio.
- So, time passes and comes 1989,
and we lose our adversary,
the Soviet Union collapses.
As a cold warrior, who we
will talk about the job
you took on in a minute, that
you had to show flexibility,
you had to change your
thinking about the world
because the paradigm had
collapsed, the bipolar world
was no longer what defined the structure
of the international system.
How did you adjust mentally?
Before we talk about the
project you undertook.
- Well, first of all,
it wasn't an adjustment,
it was 180 degree turn.
That's where the deep reading
and Russian culture came
to the floor.
Granted, I didn't like what
the Russian's could do to
us during the Cold War,
but I also was well aware
of their history and literature.
I certainly knew how
many (mumbles) divisions
they held down on the Eastern
front during World War II.
I had little difficulty pulling that 180
and deciding that it
was my job to help this
highly cultured community, country,
find a new way in the world.
They had a lot more problems than I had.
But you're absolutely
right, I reversed direction.
- And, you know, there was
a debate in the country
and some would argue one
of the factions swarming
around Washington at this time would say
kick them when they're down,
boast about winning
the Cold War and so on,
so, what, in your background, do you think
what we've discussed thus
far, made you flexible?
Was it, as you just said,
just the steep learning
about what Russia was without communism?
- Both aspects, the cold
warrior and the uncold warrior,
came into play.
I've all ready covered the high
regard for Russian culture.
But I also was well aware that they still
had their nuclear weapons,
they had their missiles,
and anarchy, chaos in the
former Soviet Union, in Russia,
and could devastate the world.
So, I was strongly
motivated to do whatever
could be done to bring
stability to Russia,
help them in anyway we
could to make sure that they
could control the formidable
weapons that they had created.
- So, at this time in the Congress,
generates a bipartisan
notion about what can be done
in the context of a
collapsing Soviet Union
with nuclear weapons and so on.
And one of the Perry colleagues
or associates, Ash Carter,
who was at Harvard and then
in Washington, had an idea.
And what was that idea?
- Professor Carter decided
that it was in America's
best interest to use our
money and our know how
to cooperatively, and I
underline cooperatively,
help the Russians dismantle their arsenal,
which they and we no longer needed.
Ash Carter was very
effective in convincing
Senator Nunn, democrat,
Chairman of the Senate
Arm Services Committee, and
Richard Lugar, republican,
Chairman of the Ranking
Minority of the Foreign
Relations Committee, to
put together a bill that
would allow US dollars to
be used with the approval
of the Russian government,
to stabilize their arsenal
in this new era when we
were certainly not enemies,
maybe not friend yet, but
certainly, we needed to cooperate.
- So, you're talking about
a very different Washington.
- Yes, indeed.
(men laughing)
- You've used the word idea,
and this is a good idea,
let's do something about it.
And we're talking bipartisanship,
but it's not just two
senators, they're able to
work it through the Congress.
- Absolutely.
- And get it signed by the President.
- That's right, and of course,
they were the equivalence
to Nunn and Lugar in the House
that had to do the same thing.
- And this legislation was
signed by President Bush?
- Yes, President HW--
- HW Bush, right, right.
- Yes.
That was in, that was, well,
it was late in the Bush administration.
- And so, what was the
name of the baby that
was delivered by this
very different Congress
and Washington world at that time?
- The Cooperative Threat
Reduction Program.
Also, Ash's idea, and of course,
we quickly used the acronym CTR,
Cooperative Threat Reduction.
- And again, the idea
was to act responsibly,
to help the Soviet Union
deal with a problem,
and interestingly enough,
to do this was both
in America's national
interest for reasons that
you just described, but it
was also in the interest
of international security,
in addition to the Russian interest.
- That's exactly right, I
couldn't put it better, Harry.
- And so, in a way this
is a world in which
US Foreign and Defense
Policy still is motivated
in the way that it was
motivated with the Martial Plan,
do something good for
the world that's in our
national interest, and it
will bring world security.
- We often modestly refer to
it as our little martial plan,
and in a very real
sense, as you point out,
that's exactly what it was.
- So, when the Clinton
administration came in,
it was given the agenda of
implementing this project.
And there are a lot of
key actors here that we
need to really emphasize.
The most important,
probably, being now Secretary
of Defense Perry, actually.
And what were his talents
that he brought to
this endeavor that made it happen,
beyond picking you to run the program?
(men laughing)
- Well, he picked the right people,
we've all ready covered that.
Secretary Perry had to
take on some extremely
difficult bureaucratic tasks.
In the Bush administration,
then Secretary Cheney.
- HW Bush, yes.
- HW Bush, didn't spend any
of the money, for good reason.
Nunn and Lugar were only
able to appropriate money,
they weren't able to...
Pardon, they were only able
to authorize expenditures,
they weren't able to appropriate,
which is consistent
with the committees that
they chaired, or were on.
So, the Pentagon could spend the money,
but they had to find it
somewhere else in the Pentagon.
Those are bureaucratic,
that's a bureaucratic problem
at the first order, and Mr. Cheney,
late in the administration,
decided to not take
that one on, and I have to assume that
President Bush agreed with it.
Bill Perry was cut from a different cloth,
and it was the beginning
of a new administration.
Bill took on those
battles, found the money,
and therefore, then in
essence, could put it in my
portfolio to carry out the program.
- And he had to take this money
from some of the services?
- That's right, who have their
own connections to the hill,
to the White House, to the press.
One of Bill's many talents
is his soft spoken ways.
So, by any standard, these
are grandiose battles
within the Pentagon, but yet,
the public, I don't think,
heard about it, I don't
think the Chiefs went
to the White House.
There was a lot of trust
between Secretary Perry
and the Pentagon's bureaucracy.
- And he, in terms of command and control,
if we can use those terms,
he saw the importance
of centralizing this effort where?
- Very good question.
Ordinarily, programs like this
that involve foreign affairs,
budgetary considerations,
certainly the military,
those problems are
traditionally managed by
the National Security
Council because it brings
together the various forces of government.
But that's not the way you
run a fast moving program,
so Bill effectively took the
management away from the NSC
and put it right in the
Pentagon, so that Ash Carter,
who by that time was the
Assistant Secretary of Defense
for Policy, Ash wrote the
policy of what should be done.
Bill approved it, it was my
job to implement that policy,
all within the Pentagon.
It was a masterful job of
bureaucratic management.
- And were you all
prepped to do this because
of the work of the shadow
government that we had talked.
I mean, was this, in
addition to Ash's idea,
was this something that
was part of an agenda,
or did it only happen once
you had the strings of power?
- I think we were prepared
to take on the task,
but I don't think we had
thought through the task.
So, we were really starting from scratch.
It was hard going.
- So, you had to assemble
and deploy a team.
And this is a team that draw
on the best expertise of
the American government,
especially the Pentagon
and other security related
agencies and so on.
So, how did you define
the problem, basically?
I mean, this is a big thing
to be thrown on your desk
and you have an eight billion
dollar budget to work with.
- Well, eight billion over 10 years.
- [Harry] Over 10 years, right.
- But I had well over half a billion--
- [Harry] In the beginning, yeah.
- That had to be allocated adequately.
Well, one of the agency's
that reported to me
was then called The
Defense Nuclear Agency,
it's now called The Defense
Threat Reduction Agency.
But I had to turn to them
to negotiate contracts
with entities, whether
American or Russian,
to carry out the tasks the
policy said we should carry out,
dismantling missiles,
moving warheads, et cetera.
I went to that agency
and explained that this
was not dealing with American industry,
they were going to be
dealing with Russian industry
and (mumbles) bureaucracies.
And remember, Russia had
essentially a command economy,
not a market economy.
So, there was never a great
need in the Russian sphere
to know what things cost,
price didn't matter.
Production was what counted.
So, the program managers,
who are ordinary,
well, not ordinary, extraordinary,
but they are bureaucrats,
they are government servants.
They had to master how you
negotiate with something
you have all the money and
they have all the products
that are going to be operated on.
And they want to get as much
of your money as possible,
and we wanna dismantle as many
of their weapons as we could.
That's an all together different
way of writing contracts
than ordinary--
- So, when I've heard you
talk about this before,
at a recent lecture at RGS,
really it's about building a team.
And let me walk you briefly
through the elements,
because there were individuals
who really mattered.
So, from intelligence you got
a general, a major general,
who basically really knew the
Soviets as well as you did
in the security field.
- Yes, there are a lot
of unsung heroes here.
One of them, some of them, of course,
are the bureaucrats that
negotiated the contracts.
Another group are the prime contractors
of the United States,
Bechtel was a good example.
Experienced in major
projects all over the world,
plenty of language expertise, et cetera,
they had to report to me on
how the money was being spent,
and yet, they had to hire
Russian subcontractors
in a society that was unfortunately
renowned for corruption.
And to their credit, the
prime contractors that we used
never lost a penny and in
practically every case,
did a very fine job, whether
you measure it by production,
or in this case dismantlement,
accidents, et cetera.
So, the prime contractors
(mumbles) really deserve
a heavy round of applause here.
- And this was at a time,
this is ancient history,
because this was at a time
when the American government
could do things in a non corrupt way
and get the project done.
That's just an editorial
point there I'm making.
- But it's accurate.
(men laughing)
- Yeah, it's accurate, and in
retrospect, very impressive
because apparently that
hasn't been our experience
in the recent wars that we've fought.
But talk about some of these individuals.
- I will.
- So, Major General Lajoie
was really important,
and he came from the CIA.
- Well, Roland Lajoie
is the key to success.
I mean, granted Ash ran policy,
I implemented the program,
but it was Lajoie who was
responsible for the day
to day running of the program,
and he did an absolutely magnificent job.
He's an army officer, ROTC.
He was fluent in Russian, so
fluent that, in my presence,
he could banter with the Russians.
So, he had a good sense
of what they were saying.
When I first met General Lajoie,
he was the top man in the CIA,
Central Intelligence Agency,
for advising the director on matters,
Russian or Soviet then,
and the Russians knew it.
But Roland was retiring about
the time I came into office,
and noted that he was retiring.
And I turned the Pentagon upside down
to make sure we hired him, and we did.
He is the man who deserves, I think,
most of the credit for the
success of the program.
- But your interpreter was
also important, Nahanov?
- [Harold] Irene Nahanov.
- And she was important
because she served as both
a PR person, but also a
person who could work Russian
culture and enhance your
standing vis-a-vis the Russians
because of your Russian side
agenda throughout your career
of learning about Russia, it's
history and it's literature.
- Very well put.
She was the publicist,
and in side conversations
where I wasn't present, she
made sure that they knew
that I had read War and Peace twice,
I'd used Pontryagin's
theorems, was well read
on Russian music, I
appreciated deeply the Russian
role in World War II.
She just absolutely enhanced
my reputation as a person
the Russian's could trust.
At the same time, she
proved to them that she was
trustworthy, and anecdotally,
the way to demonstrate
that is that she had
telephone numbers for every
Russian official for
whom we were dealing that
she could use and get them at
any time of the day or night,
and we did.
And I should add that
this idea of their trust
of Irene Nahanov also
pertains to Roland Lajoie.
Even though he had spent
his life, his career,
in intelligence, the Russians
came to trust him very much.
- And also important
on the Russian side was
your counterpart, General Maslin.
- [Harold] Yes.
- Who essentially had
a similar kind of role
being in charge of the
non active nuclear weapons
that the Soviet Union controlled.
- That's right, before I
take on that question, Harry,
one more point about Nahanov.
In addition to be a
publicist, fine interpretor
quite often, the Russians
would have her interpret
both sides of the conversation.
But where she showed
her skills as a diplomat
was when the negotiations got intense.
And they frequently did.
She would, at some
point, interrupt and say,
"Dr. Smith, tell the
Russians about Natalia."
I said, "Good idea, Irene, please do."
Since I couldn't tell the story.
And she would tell the
story of our first child,
who was born shortly after
I read War and Peace,
and we christened her
Natalia for the heroine
of War and Peace.
Well, when a talented woman
tells this endearing story,
tensions relaxed, faces
were no longer stressed,
negotiations proceeded.
And she did this time and time again,
in just the right way,
just the right time,
she was a great negotiating tool.
But now, I should return
to General Maslin.
Maslin's portfolio was the (mumbles),
and that's a Russian acronym.
But essentially he had
the same responsibilities
to his government as I
had to mine in the world
of nuclear weapons.
I had other responsibilities.
But every weapon that was not
in the care of a commander
that is on alert, was his responsibility.
And Maslin had to, therefore,
move all the technical
nuclear warheads after the fall,
after the collapse of the Soviet Union,
he had to move those
weapons back to Russia,
which he did as fast as possible,
and without any American assistance.
But that left, of course,
all the strategic weapons,
the weapons that could
reach the United States,
sill there in Ukraine,
Belarus, Kazakhstan.
He was responsible to
work with the Americans,
to get those weapons back,
dismantle the missiles,
defuel the engines that had been built,
make sure the weapons
got to storage sights
where they could be secure.
That was his responsibility.
- And both interestingly
here, a great deal of trust
was built between you and him.
And some of that trust was built by
the extent to which each
side sensed the importance
of culture to the Russian
nation, to rural culture,
and so on, so he was a man
who appreciated world art.
You were a man who
appreciated Russian culture
and Russian literature, there
were exchanges in which,
on his side, he took
you to the battlefield
in War and Peace, and to
museums, and to ballet.
On your side, working with
our former Chancellor Hammond,
who is now head of the
Smithsonian Institute.
You arranged for him to
tour American cultural
centers and so on, and so
that was very important
to cementing the security aspects.
- It certainly was, Harry,
and you put it very well.
Just one anecdote perhaps?
- [Harry] Yes.
- Maslin treated me to
the tour of Borodino,
and it was well done.
I wanted to make sure I
could respond in kind,
and so I called Theresa Hammond,
Chancellor Hammond's wife,
and asked Theresa if
she'd like to do her bit
for national security.
She was quite effective
in managing aspects
of the National Gallery,
and I noted for her that
General Maslin, that
grew up in St. Petersburg
and spent many, many
hours in the Hermitage,
was well read in the
French impressionists.
And Theresa said, why, of course.
So, one evening we
assembled, Nahanov, myself,
General Maslin, and Phillip Coningsby,
the curator for the Smithsonian,
for the National Gallery
on French impressionists,
and he was a strange man.
It was late at night and
you could hear our footsteps
echoing in this empty gallery.
And Coningsby was very
careful, he began his lecture
to General Maslin, who was
dressed in full military regalia,
at my insistence.
- And what Maslin's question?
- Well, Coningsby said,
"General, the French impressions
"were French, and they were painting
"in the late 19th century."
Maslin, of course, knew all that,
which Coningsby wasn't
going to make a mistake.
Maslin asked a very sensible question.
And Coningsby quickly figured out that he
had to ratchet up the...
And so, he did, he point
out some rather subtle
things about the French impressionists.
Maslin said, I understand,
but he had another question.
And very shortly, the
conversation was beyond me,
that it was too aficionados
of French impressionism
discussing it, and it
went very, very well.
It ended when General
Maslin had a question for
Mr. Coningsby, Dr. Coningsby, he said,
"Phillip," being his first name,
"I don't see any Signac's
here in the gallery."
And Coningsby was crushed
because there are none,
or there were none.
He said, "Alas General,
we have none such."
Maslin smiled knowingly, a little sadly,
and said, "We do."
- So, in the end, the program
accomplished an awful lot,
and let me just list some of the things--
- By the way, Harry, I
should add, General Lajoie's
opinion wasn't, that exchange of culture,
particularly in the night
of the National Gallery,
was a turning point.
From that point on, Maslin
trusted the Americans,
and of course, we trusted him.
I just wanted to make sure that was--
- And so, and in the end, you
accomplished an awful lot.
Let me just go over, you
removed all the strategic
warheads and vehicles from
Ukraine, Belarus, and Kazakhstan.
You enabled Russia to meet
the conditions of start one,
signed by Gorachev and Bush in 1991.
And you set the stage for
further start treaty talks,
and the most important
for you, you built 24
secure storage sites and
trained the personnel who
manned them, and there
has been none worthy...
There had been no security
sites before your program.
So, in essence, you
achieved an awful lot that
made our world, today, more secure.
- I think so, and one of
the reasons I'm most pleased
that you bring up these security sites is
that there's a lot of photos
looking into empty silos,
or blowing up silos, or
dismantling rocket engines,
real photo ops.
I doubt that the press has
ever shown the 24, I think,
security sites that we built.
And that was absolutely key
in a world where nuclear
terrorism was on the rise.
The Russian weapons had to be
(mumbles) put in secure sites,
they had them all over the place.
They were padlocked, so to speak,
but we installed multi-fencing,
security cameras,
personnel reliability
programs to make sure that
the guards weren't on drugs or alcohol.
All the things necessary
to keep those weapons,
which we had laboriously,
we, the Russians and
(mumbles), brought together,
made sure they stayed there.
The theft of one, two,
or three nuclear weapons
in the hands of extremists
would have caused
enormous damage in this world.
- We're living in a very
different world today.
Looking back on this
extraordinary achievement,
what do you see as the
lessons learned that
you could pass onto the next generation?
- Excellent question.
The first thing, of course,
is what I, by chance,
was able to do myself,
that is know the culture,
know how they're thinking.
If you can learn a language,
so much the better.
Russian is a tall order
but you've got to know
the feelings of the people
with whom you're dealing.
More to that point, we
learned how to put ourselves
in the Russian shoes.
So that we knew when
we were offending them,
and avoided those situations.
That was probably the number one,
that's probably the
number one characteristic.
You might say it all
started here at Cal when
I learned how to listen
what graduate students said,
and I learned, later,
how to listen what CEO's
and Vice President's had to say.
So, it's a sense of, it's antenna,
reading how the other guy feels.
That was, I'd say, the
major reason that so much
trust built up between us.
- And it's important to
emphasize that all of these
cultural aspects, history
and art, and so on,
scientific exchanges, which
are apparent in the work
that you did citing a
Russian mathematician.
They bring out the mutual respect and
sense of dignity of the other that makes
the cooperation possible, is that fair?
- Not only fair but well put, eloquent.
- And in the end, what's
gone wrong, do you think,
in today's world?
There are obviously different leaders.
Russia has done things that
appear to not be appropriate,
according to our
definition of international
and national security.
Have we made mistakes?
- Yes, we've made mistakes
and so did the Russians.
What disappeared because
of those mistakes is trust.
Today no one would accuse President Trump
or President Putin of being
paragons of honesty and trust.
And we've paid a heavy price for that.
And we've made mistake even
in the Clinton administration.
The one I'm most aware of
the decision to expand NATO,
and that's a clear case
of not thinking through
how the other guy feels.
Suddenly, his satellites
are on the other side of,
what George Kennadis
called the new Cold War,
the new iron curtain.
The Pentagon fought
that decision very hard.
Dr. Perry didn't need any
convincing that we should
postpone expanding NATO.
He made that clear to President Clinton,
and the President said he disagreed.
Bill asked for a meeting of
the National Security Council
and made his case there.
Strangely enough, Lake and Christopher,
Secretary of State and the
National Security Advisor,
were silent but Vice
President Gore felt that
we could handle this.
I think he was wrong, I think he misjudged
the Russian reaction.
So, we lost, we expanded NATO.
Whereas, I think, we
could've built on the trust
that we'd developed something to act on.
Actually, Vladimir Putin's
mention early 2000's
that Russia would consider
being part of NATO.
Well, we missed that train.
Now, that's not to say that the Russians
didn't make mistakes, (mumbles)
and causing trouble in
the Ukraine, et cetera.
- One final comment here,
you called your lecture
at IGS on this program a moment in time.
And at the end of your
lecture, you mentioned a gift
from the Russian General, which, I guess,
had been a top secret book
before he gave it to you.
But there was an inscription
and he had written
in the inscription, East
is East and West is West,
and never the twain shall meet,
was the quote from Kipling.
But you went and checked the source and
there was more to that.
- Well, if you'd look at
the (mumbles) of the book,
which I wanna add was
declassified by the time I got it.
There's an inscription at
the top of the front of this
piece in handwriting, but it's Russian.
So, of course, Irene
Nahanov translated it for me
and it's what you might expect.
It's Dr. Harold Smith, with
appreciation, et cetera.
It was heartfelt, but
below that in English,
in the same hand, it's not
to say it was necessarily
Maslin's hand, but in the same hand,
is East is East, and never
the twain shall meet.
But what most of us don't
know is that particular
stanza ends with "There is
neither border nor bleed,
"nor birth that shall"...
- I have it here if you would like.
- All right, go ahead.
- But there is neither
East nor West border,
nor breed, nor birth,
when two strong men stand
face to face, though
they come from the ends
of the earth.
- Thank you, Harry.
You'd think I'd remember it.
But that's a metaphorical
compliment of the first order,
and Dr. Perry and I agreed, in writing,
that this was a wonderful way to summarize
the trust that had built up
between Maslin and Smith,
Russia and the United
States, and now alas,
that trust is gone.
I think we're going to have
to wait for a new generation
of leaders and try again to
build the kind of relationship
that would make the two
nuclear superpowers cooperate
as we did then, in the future.
- Looking back, one final
question, looking back
at your intellectual journey,
is there one important
lesson for you that made this
great achievement possible,
and your participation in it?
- Well, of course, it's
keep reading, keep studying,
keep searching for new
solutions to today's problems.
They all happen to come at the floor when
I was at the Pentagon.
- And if you're a scientist,
don't just focus on the math,
(men giggling)
but as (mumbles) read the
literature of whatever
country you're gonna have to deal with.
- Very true, we all should be (mumbles)
as General Maslin was.
He was a military man who
knew the French impression.
In my case, I was a reader of history who
happened to be a scientist.
- Well, on that note,
Harold, I wanna thank you
for taking the time to
coming on our program
and reviewing this remarkable achievement
when the West could talk to the East,
and with a very effective
result, thank you.
- Thank you, Harry, it's a great
pleasure to tell this tale.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(intriguing rhythmic music)